man if you've been with somebody
every man and woman who have ever been
in a relationship have had this
conversation and my wife and i finally
talked about it
so i said to her one night i go hey you
want to roll around which is our set if
you've been with someone long enough you
have a saying for me
sex like ours as you want to roll around
does anybody have something they want to
what do you guys do
stretching
my man's packing some heat huh
you want me to go stretch you out
[Applause]
yeah that is a confident dude right
there
yo i'm sure the first time you said that
to her she was like what
you want me to go stretch you out a
little bit no i don't that sounds
terrible i don't want that
you want me to make it so nobody else
can use it ever
[Applause]
ah
[Applause]
good lord
if i said that to my wife she'd be like
yeah right
well
tip of the hat to you sir
[Applause]
anyways
okay uh what were we talking about
oh yeah so
i said to my wife i'm stretching it
okay
i said
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
i should take my edible after that
all right so
by the way deke where are you
[Music]
he's not stretching anybody i know that
for sure
i went to high school with him he unless
unless he stretched himself a little bit
he's not stretching anybody else that's
for [ __ ] sure
so uh
[Laughter]
um
my wife and i finally had this
conversation right and i'm sure all of
you have had it so i said to her i go
hey you want to roll around
and she said to me she goes
[Music]
i mean i'm tired i'll just lay there and
i was like
okay
every single woman in here has used that
excuse and every dude you've ever been
with has been like i don't give a [ __ ]
if you're tired or not
[Applause]
i don't even care if you move that
doesn't affect what i'm going to be
doing at all you know what i mean i know
that so every woman is like i'm just
going to tell them i'm tired and i won't
be into it and every guy is like i don't
give a [ __ ]
i'm gonna stretch it out whether you're
moving or not
[Music]
whoo boy
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
let me ask you a question hold on a
second who's in the middle who's this
dude here
he's just been like this the whole time
[Applause]
yeah you better be careful if he's
stretching [ __ ] out you're a little
closer
wow that was
definitely worth me coming here this
weekend
[Applause]
ugh
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]